I don't know how many of you watched The
Bachelor the show The Bachelor but I
just finally spent on the air for 16
seasons Wow 16 seasons yeah I couldn't
believe it
and some people have pointed out that in
that whole time there has never been an
african-american bachelor well here to
talk about this apparent lack of
diversity is one of our writers Deon
called Deon
Thank You Conan really bachelor and 16
seasons you haven't had one black
bachelor and look flavor love don't
count all right that was a basic-cable
no offence gone nothing anyway I am
tired of waiting on ABC to have a black
bachelor so you know what I did I went
out and shot my own bachelor take a look
[Music]
ladies you are all beautiful but here's
some things I'm looking for my bride I'm
looking for a woman who's strong not
that strong I'm also looking for a woman
who would that meet you run my fingers
through her hair will be proud of me and
introduce me to their parents and I'm
sorry ladies but I'm looking for a woman
who doesn't already have kids unless
they're my kids
looks like we got ourselves a show we're
very happy for you Deon Cole everybody
good work
you